Aquí tenemos un número. Pausa el video e
intenta ponerlo en su forma escrita. Muy bien,
ahora trabajemos juntos. Primero observemos
el 8. Este 8 está en el lugar de las centenas,
este es el lugar de las unidades, este es el lugar
de las decenas y este es el lugar de las centenas,
así que estamos trabajando con 8 centenas.
Entonces podemos empezar a escribir el número
como ochocientos -tenemos ochocientos y, todavía
falta más-. Ahora, podemos observar el 6 y decir:
tenemos 6 decenas, que es lo mismo que 60, y, por
último, tenemos 5 unidades, entonces tenemos 865,
así que vamos a escribirlo: ochocientos sesenta
y cinco. Ahí lo tienes. Ahora tenemos el número
865 en su forma escrita: ochocientos sesenta
y cinco. Bien, ahora vayamos en el sentido
contrario. Pondré un número en su forma escrita,
y me gustaría que tú lo escribieras en su forma
numérica, así que intentemos con este. No quiero
decirlo en voz alta porque esto te ayudaría
bastante; quiero que te esfuerces en esto.
Escribe este en su forma numérica. Muy bien,
vamos a trabajar juntos. ¿Con cuántos cientos
o centenas estamos trabajando? Bueno, aquí
nos dicen: tenemos 200, así que si pensamos en su
valor posicional tenemos el lugar de las centenas,
el lugar de las decenas y el lugar de las
unidades; entonces ¿cuántas centenas tenemos?
Tenemos dos centenas, doscientos. Ahora, ¿cuántas
decenas y cuántas unidades tenemos? Bueno,
ya escribimos las dos centenas, todo lo
que sabemos ahora es que tenemos 30. Bueno,
sabemos que podemos escribir al 30 de esta
forma, y que esto es lo mismo que tres decenas,
así que podemos escribir tres, justo aquí, en
el lugar de las decenas. Y, ahora, ¿qué hay del
lugar de las unidades? Bueno, si tuviéramos
treinta y algo entonces ese algo nos diría
el número de unidades, pero esto es sólo 30; esto
lo que nos dice es que no tenemos unidades aquí,
entonces tenemos dos centenas, tres decenas
y cero unidades o doscientos treinta.